this episode of congratulations
number 47 is brought to you by the cash
app it's a great app I use it all the
time
everybody's switching everybody in my
cult is switching it to the cash app and
it's the number one finance app in the
App Store so what are you doing they've
introduced the cash cart a new black
debit card that you can design yourself
via the app allowing you to use the cash
that you keep in the app anywhere you
want so it's very cool it's the best way
to pay people back
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now we got the merch all
restocked
[Music]
so all you got to do is go on there and
for your last-minute Christmas gifts you
can just go to Crystal calm and you can
even do gift certificates there if you
know somebody is a baby and you want to
send them a gift certificate to get any
kind of shirt that they want on their
[ __ ] pot on their about what am I
saying any kind of shirt about the
podcast or whatever the [ __ ] anyway so
that's what's up and then I'm in it's
episode 47 and we're nearing at the end
of the year and christmas is coming
mm-hmm been having all those Christmas
song stuck in my head talked about it
last week and I'm good I'm feeling good
I was sick a little bit my voice is
still is I you know one like you do the
thing where you're like yeah I'm not
gonna get sick by the way everybody's
sick right now everybody I know is sick
right now my brother my friends my
everybody but it's the the kind of thing
we were like I'm not gonna get sick I
did it like for like seven days I was
like now I'm good it's probably longer
actually I remember I was in Irvine and
also San Jose
I feel no it was like probably ten days
of it and then finally for two days I
was like oh no and it was the day out
one of the days I shot the good doctor
oh my god so I was meeting everybody
mm-hmm being all sick which is cool
probably got them all sick great I hate
that I hate being sick and having to
meet people because you have to do the
[ __ ] fist bump thing but you just
seem like a pompous [ __ ] even though
you're even if you're sick you could
literally have like the [ __ ] bird flu
or whatever they had in that movie
outbreak with Dustin Hoffman and and you
could be like oh yeah I'm a little under
the weather let me let me do a fist bump
and you still think that guy's a pompous
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
how many movies was Dustin Hoffman in
where he played somebody that had to
like would that I had to like wear a
[ __ ] space space helmet but wasn't in
outer space I would say three I think
three outbreak sphere and the one Meet
the Fockers
no but Destin Dustin Hoffman literally
it would only would be like I'll do a
movie as long as I get to wear a
spacesuit and don't have to go to outer
space in it that's so funny to think
about actually Ishtar you know he wore
that in Ishtar so mm-hmm
so uh yeah 2017 is coming to that but
I've been on my 2018 ship since [ __ ]
March so I don't want to talk about I
don't want to talk about that [ __ ] I
don't talk about I do a year ahead I've
been watching that show dark on Netflix
I'm about seven episodes in no clue what
the [ __ ] is going on
but it's great and I like things where I
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on cuz
at least it's like surprising me like my
one of my top five favorite movies ever
Mulholland Drive don't know what the
[ __ ] going on no clue zero clue David
Lynch doesn't tell us he's a director
you gotta watch some movie don't know
what's going on you go like this what's
going on the whole movie then it ends
and you think wait a minute and then
you're [ __ ]
the selected of the weirdest ship and
they sing that [ __ ] Silencio song you
know with a blue guy anytime there's a
blue guy singing alone on earth on a
stage I'm in that [ __ ] movie what's
the one with Chris Tucker and Bruce
Willis Fifth Element if Dustin Hoffman
was in a space suit blue singing on the
theater not in outer space favorite
movie of all time but dark is [ __ ]
it's really good and and and it is
basically like the [ __ ] hardcore
version of stranger things stranger
things I feel like God caught a little
bit of heat and was on the and it caught
on the whole like oh I like that show
but I'm saying it because I lot of
people like that show this [ __ ] show
is like just hardcore it's like the
underground [ __ ] and it's German but
they do the they don't they don't do
subtitles which kind of bothers me but
then once you get into it you get into
it but they do like they do like the
[ __ ] uh they dub it which is weird
and it anytime I I hear dub
dubbing [ __ ] it's like it's
automatically Asian I don't give a [ __ ]
like it's like Jackie Chan's in it and
it's rumble in the Bronx they're like
and it and it's always bad actors to
that do that and then you see the people
like cry and breaking down or like where
the [ __ ] is my son but it's like where
is my son you know where they're like
crying and [ __ ] and you're like I
haven't seen him for a week now and it's
like just you see there they're [ __ ]
you see them getting more and more Asian
but the show dark is good and it's a
little bit like it did it has to do with
time travel I any show any movie or any
show about time travel is always too
much like theorizing and [ __ ] like
there's a little bit of that and it's
like I don't give a [ __ ] I'm too dumb
I'm too dumb don't talk to me about
[ __ ] higgs-boson you know I mean
don't talk to me about splitting the
atom don't talk to me about [ __ ]
like oh well the wormhole anytime you
say wormhole and we tripped it up and
there's three dimensions I'm out I'm
done I'm done get it just show me the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
show me the CARFAX show me the CARFAX
you know that [ __ ] thing that
commercial anyway you got to check out
dark I'm seven episodes in no clue what
the [ __ ] is going on but it's great
cryin over you that's what the [ __ ]
David Lynch movie Mulholland Drive so
anyway my favorite thing that happened
this past week and maybe in history was
when Mario Batali said sorry for sexual
harassment by the way try my Cinnabons
favorite thing that happened in the past
however many years
oh dude so sorry for being a [ __ ]
gross male Pig by the way these new
cinnamon desserts are great for the
holidays
hey man by the way he doubled down maybe
he might be maybe that's the key to
keeping your career I mean they must
have fired him right but when he put the
[ __ ] email out where he was like I'm
so sorry I shouldn't have done this my
apologies by the way if you're looking
for a holiday treat that guy is a
sociopath he doesn't give a [ __ ] but
that guy just looks like a guy you know
what Mario Batali looks like he looks
like a guy who got a belly to be extra
creepy so he could lay his [ __ ]
interlaced fingers on it and be like my
my what great milky breasts to a woman
and then walk away and be like he
literally looks like Oh Mario Batali
looks like a guy who Dirk's off and then
by himself and then has an orgasm and
then laughed so hard afterwards because
I get was such a great release and he
laughed so hard that he can't that he
starts crying and then he's wiping tears
away like and then he cleans himself up
how much does Mary
vitaliy only masturbate with the windows
open and like the breeze coming in and
he feels the breezin it turns him on cuz
it's like he's so relaxed he's like I
just like feeling the earth you know and
then he laughed so hard after he
masturbates and then he [ __ ] tears
come out of his eyes and then he's like
ah [ __ ] and then he goes to his own
kitchen and makes like some pork [ __ ]
with like a nap with that with like an
apple [ __ ] sauce on it [ __ ]
my my those are beautiful milky breasts
that's you know II I mean it looks like
a guy who [ __ ] do that he looks like
I mean you don't grow your hair out you
don't grow your red hair out and get a
fat [ __ ] belly and wear a [ __ ]
Patagonia fleece vest while you're
cooking to not look at women and say my
what a figure I mean come on
the guy looks like a [ __ ] pimp give
him a you know what he I mean give him a
cane give him a [ __ ] bunch of rings
and put a [ __ ] fur coat on him with
oversized gold glasses and make him
smack hoes and get money
my my how evil not not surprised for a
second not surprised for a second also
take off your Crocs duty wears orange
Crocs whoo I mean this guy looks like a
guy who would be like blah blah blah and
grab girls butts
blah blah blah that turns him on uh what
by the way I thought he was gay I I
thought he was gay
yeah do you know I mean he's gay he's
gotta be gay look at that
Orange Crocs blue and light blue striped
socks [ __ ] what do you call that
plaid shorts blue a green vest orangish
button-down under it and an orange tie
and orange goatee and an orange long
hair and yeah obviously go up up above
bub when you grab crossbones there's no
question Mario Batali's Italian dude I'm
so sorry for all the sexual harassment
and I know this is inappropriate but I
just want you to know if you are looking
for [ __ ] cinnamon flavored [ __ ] on
the holidays here you go
I'm sorry I am sorry it doesn't mean you
don't want to [ __ ] to have a good
taste bud good good taste during the
holidays anyway these are good Cinnabon
cinnamon shits and also turnaround
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh buhbuh let me grab
your butt's now it's all good Mario
Batali
I mean plaid shorts with a green vest
that's it that's all I got to say when
they said you really [ __ ] sexually
harassed a bunch of women all you had to
do was say plaid shorts and a green vest
bye
and then go wee everyone by the way how
much well I don't know why these guys
who don't get caught for anything not
even sexual harassment just anything as
long as it's not murder or like
kidnapping but like some like I mean I
guess sexual harassment is very very bad
but like anything from like any petty
crime or like anything less than robbing
two thousand dollars from from somebody
or or even a corporation is if you get
caught and you go we like if somebody
robbed me and went sorry but I'd be like
no you can keep it I mean that's so
baller you know hey hey hey Sam
trying to dig to China my [ __ ] dogs
so Sam stop trying to dig to China come
here
yeah just do that go we and you can take
the money I mean it's ridiculous getting
ridiculous what's that song yeah butters
butters was like trying to lick on Sam
stomach like he has [ __ ] teats no it's
all wet so yeah Mario Batali dude I [ __ ]
you know any of those creatures I did
one of those Bobby Flay's my favorite I
did one of those I was a select quote
unquote celebrity judge or whatever for
the food you don't do [ __ ] by the way
though it's awkward as [ __ ] in those
rooms there's a crowd above you and
you're like under and they're cooking
and [ __ ] and like it's you know that cut
it all together as a family man damn all
that [ __ ] that's so not how it is it's s
awkward you're in a dungeon basically
and I was with that one chef I can't
remember her name all she kept saying
was she's a potato [ __ ] I'll eat
anything that's a potato
I'm a potato [ __ ] and they cook such
good food and and I did the Bobby Flay
[ __ ] but was my episode called steak me
home tonight it's cute it's crafty and I
kept trying to [ __ ] up the the taping
like Bobby Flay would be like and the
secret ingredient is and I said car keys
and they come and he start laughing and
they have to redo it but like [ __ ]
those shows you know but Bobby Flay's
the [ __ ] and I he just looks like a guy
he Bobby Flay looks like a guy that like
is just so confident no matter what
happens like Bobby Flay looks like he
could [ __ ] his pants and be like oh [ __ ]
you know whatever and you'd be like I
guess people kind of do [ __ ] their pants
and then you'd be like haha hey we
should get together sometime with shitty
pants and you'd be like yeah we [ __ ]
should yeah you know what I'm talking
about
that's how Bobby Flay looks but if he
looks like that anybody who's like looks
Irish but isn't Irish but has like an
edge like a [ __ ] Boston like who
else's what you know else like that I
think he's southern but Blake Shelton's
like that bill burrs like that anybody
who who's like looks Irish but isn't
Irish but it's from like the East Coast
and that will like they look like they
could [ __ ] their pants but then be like
ah you want to [ __ ] it let's go hang
let's go watch some games and you'd be
like yeah I'll go watch some games with
you you're gonna get you can clear up
your pants be like yeah I'll get to it
that's how [ __ ] Bobby Flay look he
looks like the ultimate guy like that um
he just looks confident and charismatic
guys like that see guys like that guy
what's that man crush man crush that's
what a man crush is by the way he drives
me nuts when women post man crushes or
when a man posts woman crush Wednesday
that's for [ __ ] women to do a man
crush is for a guy to have a straight
guy alright guys he could be gay and
have one but like that's the whole
[ __ ] like irony of it my man crush is
Hugh Jackman or whatever the [ __ ] I
don't say Oh women crush my woman crush
every day Emily Ratajkowski like yeah no
[ __ ] that's my woman crush she's a woman
I'm a guy I'm a hot blooded American
male hey oh yo dude really
you like hourglass figures you like
girls with big doe eyes and lips that
look like [ __ ] my pillows you like
girls with lips that look like [ __ ]
guys with mustaches would try and
[ __ ] a hawk inside your bath
mirrors when you're brushing your teeth
get out of here I follow some of these
chicks on instagrams like Emily brought
it to chow ski bro I get angry whenever
I see it I gotta unfollow rat it to
chaski rat a Chomsky the [ __ ] is her
name lose some syllables nobody knows
her last name right she's like the most
famous girl nobody knows her last name
look at st. what is he doing now I said
his name he stopped doing I gotta
[ __ ] take a picture of him doing it
it's like the [ __ ] anyway so so
anyway yeah I was at the Comedy Store my
voice has been gone and just because
every time I get sick after I get sick
my voice goes away and it's fine and
then I get onstage and I yell for 20
minutes and it's not fine then it goes
goes away but I was at the Comedy Store
and it's been it's been you know that's
my home there you know shout out to
[ __ ] sometimes people ask me what who
your favorite comedians coming up and
[ __ ] like that and I always say like you
know whoever the [ __ ] but I got a new
one Nikki Glaser
I watched the past two nights dude this
girl is so [ __ ] funny man and I told
her this but the [ __ ] she's saying on
stage dude I'm in the back I'm howling
she's so [ __ ] funny Nikki Glaser she
had a show on Comedy Central called not
safe and I think I did it twice and I
had a blast doing it she's such a
sweetheart but I don't know if I ever
like sat down and watched her you know
as comedians you walk by the back
hallway you see the [ __ ] you see
inside you're like oh yeah [ __ ]
whoever's on stage Bobby Lee's on stage
wouldn't come
you don't watch him you know you watch
maybe your one or two favorite like I
watched Brody Stephens er bill burr or
something but I knew he was before me
like two nights in a row and I watched
her and dude I was [ __ ] howling dude
she's so funny she's so [ __ ] funny
you should check her out and and you
should uh she's getting apparently she's
moving to New York and doing a radio
show on XM but she's just [ __ ] funny
man she was killing me
she's talking about like the type of guy
she likes and her ex and it was just it
was just funny and relatable to me and
I'm [ __ ] I'm a guy you know but yeah
she's hilarious
and then the ever funny Chris Spencer
was on that guy [ __ ] kill always has
been killing me that guy may be the best
storyteller I've ever I've ever
encountered
we used to go to the [ __ ] coffee bean
and run that block in the valley and
dude this guy by the way my friend Chris
Spencer it knows everybody anybody would
walk into that coffee bean and they were
walking to be like hi and be like are
Chris what's up Eddie Murphy walked in
and Eddie was like hey what's up it's
kind of everybody he's so funny dude him
and Nikki Glaser the two of them um but
anyway you gotta check their [ __ ] out
you probably know him already but uh
yeah
should I do a ads okay mm-hmm lifts
lifts knows that their drivers are what
keep them moving so they do what so they
do everything they can to make sure
their drivers are happy on every trip
look it's a simple formula happy drivers
means happy passengers maybe that's why
nine out of ten lift rides get a perfect
five-star rating you can earn hundreds
of dollars a week plus tips you want to
earn more money drive more it's never
been easier to give yourself a raise and
Express pay let's say get paid almost
instantly instead of waiting for weeks
lyft has even taken the guesswork out of
pickups the new amp device uses color
coding to help passengers find their
drivers so it's less annoying when
you're trying to pick up your customers
join the ride-sharing custom a company
that believes
in treating its people better go to lift
calm / congrats today and you can get a
$500 new driver bonus that's lift calm /
Congrats lift calm / Congrats limited
time only terms apply and you know a
lift is great I use it you can earn it's
a it's actually it's also the first ride
share app that tipping is built right
into the app so you can just do it you
don't have to go into your crusty
pockets and get a dollar or two so it's
really really easy anyway that's lift
here's another one man crates it's
really hard to pick up to pick out the
perfect gift but all too easy to get it
completely wrong right man crates calm
is the surest way to find gifts that
guys will actually love guaranteed it's
not a cheese of the Month Club or a new
tie man crates offers over a hundred
hand curated gift collections for every
type of guy from the rugged outdoorsman
to the sports fanatic and everything in
between they sent me this cool pocket
knife and I've been flipping it out and
doing shadow stabbing all day to nobody
right just opened up a I opened up a ice
pack and it went all over my sink I I
flicked it open and went and it opened
all over my sink and I didn't know it
wasn't water and I had to it's really
tough to get all that stuff out of my my
stuff anyway
great stuff so the grill mat the grill
master Craig with a brass knuckle meat
tenderizer and a cast iron smoker box
they send you that they'll send you the
whisper whiskey appreciation crate with
a personality lies decanter and glasses
for his favorite drink you telling me
yeah yong-chol won't like that you're
telling me yong-chol won't like that
both men's health and allure magazine
are saying man crates are the perfect
gift for men and those who those two
don't agree on anything so thousands of
five-star reviews and every man crate
comes with a high-five guarantee on the
holidays go-to man crates comstock
congrats and get five percent off your
order that's five percent off at man
crates dot-com / congrats man crates
calm / congrats all that stuff though
that like the the the what do you call
it the
I did the food shows and the and all
that it's so [ __ ] the wit to describe
food when they're like when they're like
you know it really tastes very
interesting to me like food doesn't
taste interesting period okay you know
it tastes you know it tastes good you
know it tastes great you know what
tastes bad
you know what tastes spicy you know what
tastes bland you know it doesn't taste
interesting you know what it's
interesting look hmm that's very
interesting if you put something if you
put a [ __ ] bread crumb in your mouth
and you say God I that tastes very
interesting immediately you're out of my
club immediately you [ __ ]
and immediately all you do is you got to
have an ego to say mmm that's really
interesting oh you know the one let me
let me describe to you the definition of
mouthfeel the physical sensations in the
mouth produced by a particular food ooh
this Cabernet has a dense tightly woven
mouthfeel with complex chili and velvety
tannins that's what the [ __ ]
definition sentence that was if you say
any of that stuff step back a little bit
because we're in the same room get in
that different room next to this room
good gunk okay mmm has a very tightly
woven mouthfeel imagine being with
somebody at dinner imagine being on a
date and then hearing someone say that
has a really tightly woven mouthfeel
that wine has a really tightly woven
mouthfeel you know what a mouthfeel is
something too
described you can describe a [ __ ] a
[ __ ] oh that's a great mouthfeel
imagine getting your [ __ ] sucked and
being like wow what a mouthfeel dude
any guy getting a [ __ ] for the first
or second time with the girl that you're
with and you say oh what what a tightly
woven mouthfeel you're going to hell
you're going to hell above someone that
[ __ ] murdered someone well what a
mouth feel that by the way I didn't
realize this literally the most foreign
thing you can say oh wow this is a
really good mouthfeel when I eat these
pretzels with the arm with the outside
caramel on it wonderful mouthfeel it is
a wonderful mouthfeel the texture of the
title woven mouthfeel and Safari you
know a foreign porn guy took a [ __ ]
and was like oh that's a really
wonderful mouthfeel oh and here's the
thing that online the mystery of
mouthfeel what is it a [ __ ]
children's book say yeah hey turn around
see ya
why is your nose facing the nose
mouthfeel dude I want to I want to train
all [ __ ] a decade and then enter the
Octagon as the fight or mouthfeel may be
the scariest should ever I feel really
interesting doesn't it people constantly
describe things wrong they like to use
interesting words for other [ __ ]
[ __ ] like you know what the worst
thing is have I talked about this before
describing someone as nice I think I
have talked about this
on the podcast no one fires saying no
but if that's what comes to mind is
describing someone for your first
[ __ ] thing oh yeah it's really nice
I've talked about this on pockets before
[ __ ] it's the worst thing ever be
mysterious be a bad guy before you'd be
nice I gotta take a picture my daughter
the what I have I first sure have
I just didn't delete it it was in my
[ __ ] the [ __ ] the the things I have
on my podcast I have [ __ ] right here
that I don't even know what it means
this is this stuff that comedians write
in their notes so I write child
molestation and - the most Italian I
would ever be I don't even know what
that means what does that mean what does
that mean like the most [ __ ] premise
I think I was talking about be omelet
like if my kid if that happened kind of
how many shows are on Netflix about how
some kid gets molested and then like the
dad has to find the guy and the guy it
is wearing that has to wear like a and
it takes place in [ __ ] fall and the
guys want a coat with a collar can't
damn but but I figure I was I think I
was talking about it with I was like if
somebody if somebody was gonna if
somebody did that to my kid I would
[ __ ] drag him I think that's what I
was saying I would [ __ ] drag him I'd
curb I'd curb him dude and curb stomp
him and then I was talking about it and
then I was like that's almost Italian I
could ever [ __ ] be because these
[ __ ] if you cross me I'll
[ __ ] I'll [ __ ] cut y'all a shitty
slice she's a sly CEA's [ __ ] ear the
[ __ ] ear dude
you know people get lonely at the
holidays I don't know what it is what is
it about the holidays that makes you
[ __ ] feel lonely you'll be with your
whole family I feel [ __ ] lonely [ __ ]
what is it about holidays I think of my
past relationships that's what I do
I [ __ ] you'll be the song I play have
yourself a merry little Christmas and I
mean leftover turkey at 11 p.m. I my
parents house thinking about my exes may
your days be nice oh oh and I'm drinking
coke coca-cola even though I never drink
it out of a [ __ ] glass 11:30 p.m.
watching some [ __ ] die heart watching
die hard - and my dad's trying to stay
up in his [ __ ] chair you know and
he's just like boy I'm tired but I want
to stay up cuz and you know it's
Christmas and I'm hanging out and he's
just [ __ ] on his iPad Google and
[ __ ] Spencer Tracy movies may your
days be bright and I'm drinking [ __ ]
and I'm thinking about all my exes it's
a Jewish boy in a Christmas [ __ ] so
have yourself alright dude chill a merry
little Christmas I [ __ ] don't like
music dude how am I the only person in
the world that doesn't like music and
also doesn't like sports you know I
don't like music is imagine like
somebody next to you singing the [ __ ]
you're just like alright bro we're just
trying to [ __ ] chill that's basically
what it's like when you turn on music
and then you want to put on music and
have it on in the background that's what
it's good for is background [ __ ] bro if
you put my comedy on in the background
disrespectful
so you gonna play [ __ ] Coldplay in
the background
dude yo dis
spec 'full that is too [ __ ] Phil
Collins who tried to work his whole life
and make a song about some guy that saw
another guy drowning and the other guy
didn't do anything about it and you're
gonna put it on in the [ __ ] BG of my
party while someone's getting
blacked-out drunk and then some guys
trying to [ __ ] some girl [ __ ]
disrespectful that's why I don't
music isn't good unless you can [ __ ]
sit next to the guy and sing in their
face about it you know like that
freestyle that [ __ ] black thought did
for an 11 minute throw how did he do
that how did that black how did Black
Thought do that that's the best
freestyle I ever heard of my life it was
11 minutes on Funk Flex and he didn't
stop and he didn't stutter once dude
that's imagine never learned knowing how
to fruit never hearing hip-hop and then
hearing black thought [ __ ] how many
hits does I have now 1.3 million it's so
good and he never is the best freestyle
ever ever
and I don't get by the way how cold is
it in that studio him and Funk Flex are
free are are in like Funk Flex is in
like a [ __ ] would it call them ski
hat and a [ __ ] ski jacket with
leather and a [ __ ] frilly hood how
goddamn cold is it in that studio it's
got to be 20 [ __ ] degrees it's gotta
be [ __ ] zero degree Celsius I know
what that is by the way I'm so tired of
seeing the [ __ ] Christmas
the girls dressed up with the [ __ ]
titty out as the reindeer you know I'm
talking about they with the red nose and
their nipple and then the Ender titties
out I'm so tired of that [ __ ]
oh yeah it's cute now I see it every
year the girl with her [ __ ] titty out
and the eyes on the top of her tits and
the [ __ ] red nose on her titty I get
it dude and the antlers it's like that
shit's funny one time why do we have to
keep seeing that [ __ ] you've never seen
it
oh wow well people send me [ __ ] like
that all day long you know cuz they want
me to [ __ ] post about it but that's
one of those things where you look at it
and it's already annoying cuz you're
like everyone's gonna [ __ ] do it you
know I'm talking about those things it's
like did those jokes that are like how
many [ __ ] jokes it's like when you
[ __ ] yourself and Bay's around how many
how many times you
that same joke it's like that joke was
like oh you see a girl's ass and then
the [ __ ] trying not to look at the
girl's ass and then your friend [ __ ]
and then your girl sees you and you're
doing a video and some [ __ ] some
mixed-race guy is like day and it's got
40 million hits on it cuz some [ __ ]
YouTube sensation is on it [ __ ] Gucci
Mane did a song with that Jake Logan
with the [ __ ] his name
Gucci Mane did a song with the [ __ ]
whitest kid ever the guy who's trying to
be Tom green on the YouTube star guy
Jake Logan Paul Jake Paul right Logan
Paul and Jake Paul they're brothers yeah
yeah Gucci Mane did a song with them
Gucci Mane's hey guess what Gucci Mane
is done in my book
hey gucci mane sia the [ __ ] ARA you
lost me gucci mane was [ __ ] i got it
he was like [ __ ] silly cool guy
see ya oh you did a song with a [ __ ]
youtube star catcher the [ __ ] later yeah
no it's a Jake Paul song yeah I mean
how's a rapper gonna do a song with
[ __ ] Jake Paul how's that gonna
happen
gucci mane was like a here's that you
know he's like the first [ __ ] 2
Chainz or whatever or the first or the
second Cameron Cameron realest [ __ ] and
people are like mad don't do mad don't
the people are like I tweeted about it
how the [ __ ] and people are like mad
don't come at Gucci son I shut the [ __ ]
up you know he did a song with Jake Paul
the [ __ ] keep these [ __ ] in
line right Jake Logan I called him how
[ __ ] old guy is that I heard that
song it's everyday bro what's everyday
people [ __ ] love it dude these kids
love it man you will never understand
what the kids you will never understand
what the kids like you will never
understand I'm in my 30s and I you know
I'm young according to a lot of people
out there but you'll never [ __ ]
understand the next generation that's
what it is there's a younger generation
and you'll never understand my dad when
I was younger said to me hey I was like
you don't like this music and he was
like no and I was like what the [ __ ]
it's awesome and he was like you just
won't get it until you're older he was
like when you're older your kids will it
be listening to some song that's going
and I said no and there's a [ __ ] song
like that now there are songs like that
now that do that literally go listen to
the [ __ ] band
what is it fresh or now fly away what's
that song I'm gonna play this song for
you that I like because of how [ __ ]
weird it is
here we go come on I have it in my thing
I mean no no flower your way blue what's
called mesh I have it in my library
okay the guy goes oh in the song and
it's esta coming this is a song like
you're driving down parking in the
valley deep in the valley in shirt on
Sherman Way you know what I mean and
you're thinking maybe I'll go to a strip
club for the first time in [ __ ] seven
years maybe I'll see what my [ __ ]
homie is up to in Van Nuys and then
you're like yeah dude I'm genuine some
real dicey trucking [ __ ] and you're not
though but in your head you're like
maybe I'll [ __ ] have sex with a
hooker with a car use a condom though
you know I mean just because this song
is making you feel and you're like god
there's so much
Payne out there you know and then this
happens and then you're like oh so
disrespectful by the way as gave up
well how he gives up dude what is that
weird-ass song so disrespectful how it
gives up by the way right here
like is even I think'll to get coming
not getting half ass just feeling it you
know he thinks he's feeling it you know
what I mean oh this is so disrespectful
to that dude that he gives up forgot the
words
he's like gave up so disrespectful to
music you know but that songs this [ __ ]
you know why cuz he doesn't give a [ __ ]
and he knows it
I love that I play that song every time
I play that song to be able to go like
this what the [ __ ] is this and I go this
is my anthem bro cuz sometimes you do
want to just fly away cuz how [ __ ] up
the world is but also you're like maybe
I don't and that's what he means when
he's like away like you're like a kinda
wanna but not really that's so dope
another song I like is by that [ __ ]
and I forget I always forget these guys
names bro cuz they're so weird I mean my
producers trying to say hey second ad
break show up and he puts the [ __ ]
siren emoji on it like it's like
imperative we do it now one fire dude
I'll get to it you know
alright I'm gonna do these ads and then
I'm gonna [ __ ] tell you about the
[ __ ] next song let me give you a
challenge find a gift that is affordable
practical and instagram-worthy on on the
top of that list is quip the electric
toothbrush that looks like it was
designed by Apple without the high price
okay quip is the new electric toothbrush
that packs just the right amount of
vibrations into an ultra slim design
with guiding pulses to simplify better
brushing at a fraction of the cost of
bulkier brushes let me tell you
something about this quip for real it's
really good because the
electronic brushes that I've used before
they always make my gums sore but this
one doesn't it keeps it nice and fresh
and it's great quip also offers an
optional subscription plan delivering a
new brush heads on a dentist recommended
three months scheduled for five dollars
that's just five dollars including free
shipping worldwide and it's just in time
for the holidays quip is the ideal size
and price to give to give anyone on your
list fits in the stocking quip electric
toothbrush is featured Forbes GQ Oprah's
o list gift in all the gift guides this
here crib starts at just $25 and right
now when you go to get clipped comm /
congrats get your first refill pack free
with equip electric toothbrush
that's your first refill pack free at
get quick calm / Congrats
spelled get GE t qu IP comm / Congrats
square cash
it seems the babies are switching to the
cash app and it's the number one finance
app in the App Store it's because it's
the best way to pay people back you
could pay you'll pay me back you could
pay your friends back you can pay
reindeer back for the holidays Santa
Secret Santas friends family co-workers
whoever you download the square cash app
you link it to your debit card select an
amount to send type in a friend's phone
number an email address
complete the containment and then they
get a notification they've received the
money that's it I've done it tons of
times and it's awesome it's never been
this fast and free and it's it's great
its most payments can be deposited
directly in your bank account in seconds
they've got this new black debit card
that you can design yourself via the app
if you are if you artistic show your
artistic side with the with the with the
with the with the black card it's a cash
card that allows you to use the cash
anywhere you keep in the app anywhere
you want laser at your card personalize
it you could draw a code on there if you
want let people know you're a baby fan
the podcast when you're paying they go
like this oh you know about Cudas and be
like are you one nah no cooties here so
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now oh so disrespectful
it's this European band that I was
talking about as much how much they
talked about I don't like music how much
I [ __ ] talk about music and how much
I like [ __ ] music you know that cata
me yaar what you hate
JJ Lee told me that once in high school
you become what you hate think about it
every three weeks thanks JJ JJ Lee not a
more LA cañada Flintridge [ __ ] high
school name than JJ Lee we had so many
Asian kids with the last name Lee and
the first name was like [ __ ] Henry or
like the female version was like Grace
Lee I talked about this before in the
podcast Grace Lee and like Ali Linda Kim
you know [ __ ] JJ Lee you become what
you hate told me with that in [ __ ]
ninth grade goddamn do I think about it
every [ __ ] three three days you
become what you hate that's what it's
the truth dude you understand i'ope I'll
come out with a [ __ ] album in [ __ ]
15 years and I'll be like doesn't just
want to fly away Oh rolling deep in the
[ __ ] valley [ __ ] what's that song I
hate that I never remember [ __ ] band
names it's like a teen not not teen but
it's like a pop group in Europe it's SC
European my library maybe if I go to my
library
I got Apple music is that a good thing
that I got or no you onerous how do you
[ __ ] it's like dude oh there we go
and I guess it would be dance song mat
genre not it's like DAF Daft Punk Daft
it's a lot Daft Punk
it's like hump is there a bigger strip
club song than this one though by the
way this one row this I'm already
laughing come on down you got it we got
a
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies in free then a West Minister with
the [ __ ] [ __ ]
but down at Westminster we got ladies in
free it's ladies night till Tuesday
ladies night ladies in free guys in half
rise come in at 4 o'clock get your jerk
on come into 4 o'clock there's booze
well we're not allowed to say it but you
can definitely get into the booth and
probably finagle your dick out and
tongue hey guys 4:30 the day shift is
the day shift of 2 o'clock coming in at
2 o'clock there'll be one lonely old guy
there but coming in with your buddies
and you talked to a girl named destiny
and she'll bring in the back and when
the guy isn't looking that comes by in
with the checklist to see how many songs
you doing you're gonna ply your [ __ ] and
come a little bad hey guys Destiny's
coming up on stage she'll check you out
from the bag it's [ __ ] 3 p.m. why
wouldn't you then in a Westminster and
you'll come during this fire you calm
down you'll come in this part there's
nothing more there's no part mark come
above than this pie
yeah and the deep in the valley [ __ ]
definitely on Sherman Way Boulevard at
the DejaVu get a 30 minute play for a 30
minute block and come in the first
[ __ ] three minutes and then just kind
of have her rub on your tummy dick for
others the rest of the twenty seven
minutes and you pay five hundred dollars
for it
so welcome yesterday have a rubble of a
rubble of your tummy dick you'll come in
the first two minutes and thirty seconds
and then have to sit there for twenty
seven minutes and thirty seconds they'll
ask her his [ __ ] questions like you
give a [ __ ] like about where she's from
and where she moved when she was 13
[Music]
it'll be sad cuz it'll be the song in
and then and then it'll play some
[ __ ] corn song you know
then they'll play some corn song and
you'll think about how then I play this
song probably and then they'll think
about how [ __ ] the thing about how
you get [ __ ] kissed a girl one
sitting at a dance in high school to
this song and then I'll be weird cuz
you'll be sitting there with a coming
deck and you'll be thinking about a girl
named [ __ ] Rebecca back in high
school that you dance with and how our
mom was
that you earned maybe not a good guy for
and you know you are in cuz you never
thought you have mounting anything your
net but you did didn't you kind of even
though you kind of run your own business
and it's there's good years and bad
years all right
destination is good years and bad years
and you drive a Celica can you drive a
Celica and you live in a duplex you've
got two kids and one of them is from a
previous marriage yesterday what are you
doing here at 3:00 anyway did you come
yet
welcome to the stage she'll make it come
secretly
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the sage cinnamon who's a
black stripper obviously there's been no
white strippers but the name is cinnamon
it's like naming your name it's like I
mean your stripper name caramel if you
like this son you had a bad childhood if
you like this song if this song is your
favorite song there's no way your
parents are still together oh my god you
know I'm [ __ ] how [ __ ] him that was
it good
I don't know I'm [ __ ] sweating so
hard after that oh [ __ ]
Oh what else no man we have an elder oh
is it again we talked about it we just
talked about oh yeah yeah okay all right
let's name an elder our looks right here
we're not sure who the [ __ ] this is and
we like it that way you're like masta
killa from the wu-tang or whoever the
one was that wore the [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
dude I got any no no let me do the elder
first this is the new elder it's at-sea
D'Elia Photoshop why because they did
let me know in fun Photoshop things for
the new show for the show why did I send
you for the show ever since we started
ever since we started we'll we'll DM you
with the details - get your pin and
certificate but some of the [ __ ] they do
is [ __ ] hilarious go to C go to C
D'Elia Photoshop congratulations you're
an elder we'll send you the pin and the
[ __ ] and the thing the pin and the I
mean they did a [ __ ] sucking and
[ __ ] album anyway they always make
[ __ ] and it's great I got a buddy that
[ __ ] argues the wrong points man and
we were talking about it on the [ __ ]
on the group chain he's just like bro
what was the thing we were arguing about
what we I just mentioned it well I just
meant I just what oh yes yes thank you
uh Wow [ __ ] one fire - coming up with
the flashback from the episode with
black and white he was like wu-tang I
was like oh yeah I got it
so I was saying how annoying on the text
messages when artists [ __ ] cover
their faces and he was like oh dude well
you know why they do that right and I'm
like shut the [ __ ] up dude I know it
alls are the worst he's actually not a
no at all but like he just brings up the
worst points like I was talking about
girls dude you know what else is so I
say no I was like this is another one he
was like he was like you know why they
do that because what they're doing is
illegal their street artists and I was
like bro yeah I know man I know that's
why they do it but you have like [ __ ]
bands that do it and [ __ ] and like
master killer did it or one of the guys
did it on the wu-tang it's like who
gives a [ __ ] you you're a guy who cares
show your [ __ ] face you're not you're
not leading a malicious somewhere I
think he's a master killer and I mean my
producer one fire always Google's the
wrong [ __ ] he googles wu-tang mask booty
mask guy and they need to go
asked to kill her well he doesn't have a
mascot so it's not him Oh slammed me
into oblivion he just said well no I
thought it wasn't him so that's why I
forgot the first thing [ __ ] slammed me
into the next century
but and then I was talking to the guy
who [ __ ] brings up alternative points
that have nothing to do with what I'm
saying I was talking to him about how
girls always say like on social media
they always say they're from LA - no in
Wisconsin
you're not from LA if you spend two
weeks in LA a year that's like me saying
I live in [ __ ] Ohio as well cuz I
played Cleveland and Columbus this year
we'll catch you later and he was like oh
well you know why they do that and I was
like yeah because they want to seem cool
and he was like nah cuz they're hookers
s and jumping to conclusions I was like
what and he was like yeah because they
want to know they want you to know that
they can be easily booked in LA yeah
okay man sure some of the girls who do
that yeah hooking but not all of them a
lot of them like think like here's the
other thing do they'll say that because
they [ __ ] like are in an acting class
in [ __ ] Tampa or some [ __ ]
you're not in LA don't say you live in
LA if you don't live in LA and don't say
you're bicoastal if you have one [ __ ]
house don't say you're bicoastal if you
get [ __ ] air B&BS every time you go
to LA he not bicoastal if you stay with
your friend on their couch you're not
bicoastal you know you are coastal
people
to see him cool all the time yeah I live
in New York I used to know this one guy
I mean he I still know him I guess but
he'd be like yeah I live in Texas but my
heart's in New York bro if you say [ __ ]
like that we're never gonna see eye to
eye yeah no no no what my heart no no no
no he didn't say New Yorkers my heart is
he said my soul lives in New York even
worse what's a soul you know anytime
anybody talks about their soul a gunk
dude it's free conch could talk about
wherever you want but turn around dude
you're gonna talk to me about what your
soul is like get that's also one of
those things that only other people can
talk about about you any time somebody
who's like in my soul though you know
they cry more than someone who doesn't
say that you know they had a [ __ ] up
like they've been cheated on a lot any
time someone talks about their soul
they've been cheated on a lot oh man
I always feel like when to when people
are like I've been through so much
that's code for just like you've been
cheated on a few times I've been through
so much though you know especially
chicks like I've been through a lot so I
just want to make sure that this is real
between us you mean you were cheated on
twice
yeah but not well okay if you're a girl
and you haven't been cheated on you
ain't [ __ ] though that's how you become
what you become man that's how you know
what's up man you can't be all like
[ __ ] go Wonder Woman and then not
have been cheated on you know if you're
a guy
you ain't [ __ ] if you haven't been
cheated on - you know yeah you had to
have had that happen I'll tell you what
man when I was married that [ __ ]
when I got divorced and then now like
I'm so happy that that [ __ ] went down
no nobody cheated but I'm just saying
like I am I'm so happy I went through
marriage and got divorced as a young
20-something and [ __ ] now I know what
it is
because now I know it not to be taken
lightly and it's a British now I know it
not to be taken lightly but dude now I
know it not to be taken lightly man
that's some real [ __ ] and I do a lot of
jokes about how marriage is like [ __ ]
[ __ ] but like you know if I'm if I
[ __ ] I mean I'm nothing that's not
saying I would never get married again
you got it though man you got it yeah
you don't have to you don't have to but
it's like that's just one of those
things works like if you have kids and
like you with a girl and you're gonna
raise the kids with them and then yeah
you know if [ __ ] you might as well
even though the government [ __ ] take
some money up although you you uh aren't
that there are tax incentives too for
being married right all right should we
do Twitter questions did you have any
good ones
let's what's that he's good you know
yeah a couple one so you need to get a
couple ones so let's look at some
Twitter questions hey Dad
weird what are some of your favorite TV
shows movies to watch as a kid Mary at
Miriam coulda call right whatever
as a kid why is a kid okay as a kid as a
kid so as a kid I said as a kid too much
family matters I love deciever Steve
Oracle I thought he was so [ __ ] funny
man and I used to do that impression for
my cousin Nick and he would fall on the
floor
I was probably worse in person ever but
I'd be like did I do that
he would [ __ ] be crying dude um and
then uh and then what else did I like oh
no I loved oh wow oh my two favorites
were the monkeys did him here we come
when his pants would fall down with the
holster would fall down you know and
then that man with Adam West they repot
that out in the 80s oh I used to scared
the [ __ ] out of me with the penguin with
the laughing gas and [ __ ] and the
[ __ ] Joker wouldn't you diet you die
and get smile your smile would be a kind
of freaked the [ __ ] out of me and then
the fake the Batman movie with the
fake-ass shark you remember that [ __ ]
you don't watch it you had no childhood
the way
oh yeah the shark repellent dude it is
like that [ __ ] he had everything in
about utility belt you'd be like you
Robin do you need pepto-bismol be like
holy stomachaches how [ __ ] is it how
[ __ ] was Robin how [ __ ] was Dick
Grayson
holy smokes Batman holy [ __ ]
I have no [ __ ] oh so
[ __ ] dude just did whatever Batman said
and he was like 14 hey [ __ ] creepy by
the way I'm sure Robin had a few me twos
you know [ __ ] if Robin were alive
right now if Robin were a real person
he'd be like Batman you hey at Batman
remember the time you used to grope me
in the Batcave me too and people will be
like you're so brave Robin we're so
proud of you for coming forward Robin
yeah definitely [ __ ] if anybody
listen to this podcast you definitely
definitely would be in trouble for that
but anyway um what else do you play any
musical instruments Valerie Smith no I
do not [ __ ] that you know what
oh I mean this guy's just making [ __ ] up
who does that do they do that and I
skipped that one on fire I'm cute P -
what does that mean Oh cutie patootie
oh no this person Krystal Paul came
across a license plate that says I am
cutie patootie I am a cutie patootie my
princess charming is my what my prince
charming oh my god the license plate
cover says my prince charming is my son
Aiden and Aiden is spelled AAA IDE nn
hey would they have a sale on letters I
am a cutie patootie what a nightmare
this [ __ ] person must be I'm gonna go
on a limb and say it's a it's a woman
Krystle Paul is that Jake Paul's mom is
this everyday bro with her [ __ ]
license plate oh my god I am a cutie
patootie what music is a good one John
lindros at John Landrus one there was
another John Linn dress at least pick a
number that was [ __ ] identifiable to
you maybe he just thinks he's number one
which is a gym mentality what music do
you listen to when you're
rushon it at the gym I already talked
about this but you should listen to slow
celine dion [ __ ] that really gets it
going but i I don't listen to that Allah
I listen to that D to a lot of like and
like a boom bap hip-hop like DJ premier
bumping knuckles
you know like NAS type [ __ ] [ __ ] like
that that's it that's it that's it
babies Square cash have you switched yet
if no you got it do it make it one of
your new year's resolutions to switch to
the cash app screenshot it and show me
it on Twitter
download the free square cash app design
your cash card to get iOS or Android now
and we will have an episode on Christmas
it is Monday but we will have an episode
on Christmas so congratulations and
listen about that subscribe to the
YouTube channel
we got clips that come out and about the
YouTube and it's it's also the video and
it's great it's a video you get to see
me in action download the the Chris
D'Elia app for iOS or Android and also
I'll show you sometimes behind the
scenes for the [ __ ] podcast and
backstage of the Comedy Store and doing
chosen [ __ ] get some merch you can get a
for your last-minute Christmas gifts you
can get your a gift card from my website
if you know another baby and wanting to
give them something like that so go to
Chris go to Chris Leo calm for that
subscribe rate and review the show tweet
me video episodes go up on usually
Tuesdays Wednesdays I got some upcoming
shows
San Diego Riverside New Year's Eve come
join me Winnipeg Calgary Saskatchewan
Pasadena just got my flight for Canada
and Tampa Florida
I have excited to come at the end of
January I've got shows in Tampa listen
to my specials watching TV shows movies
what the [ __ ] that says definitely is
coming out I got a movie coming out the
trailers up for 1/2 magic magic movie
the movie coming out called top magic
why not thanks for this match you guys
are great thank you very much
[Music]